[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la militarisation
de l'espace lancé depuis la guerre
froide et s'accélère aujourd'hui de plus
en plus poussant les principaux acteurs
géopolitiques vers une nouvelle course
aux armements
alors où en est on dans cette
compétition à l'échelle planétaire en
mars 2021 les etats-unis accusent une
nouvelle fois la russie et la chine
d'entretenir un arsenal d'armes spatiale
or les états unis travaillent eux mêmes
à la mise en place d'un nouveau système
d'armement orbitale selon les autorités
officielles
plusieurs autres acteurs géopolitiques
ne cachent pas non plus leur ambition
spatiale france israël inde japon depuis
plusieurs années la russie et la chine
proposent leur projet d'accord
international sur la limitation des
armes dans l'espace et initiative est
d'ailleurs rejeté par washington et ses
alliés
néanmoins moss russie un certain nombre
d'accords bilatéraux visant à ne pas
déployer ce type d'armement or les
objets spatiaux tels que la lune risque
aussi de faire l'objet de militarisation
dans un futur proche les états unis sind
est traité avec leurs alliés sur le
partage des ressources lunaires une
ligne farouchement critiqué par moscou
et pékin qui prépare à tout va
leurs propres missions lunaires
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur les principaux types d'armes
spatiale c'est le bit
l'une des plus récente classification
des armes spatiales a été publié en mai
2020 par le centre américain d'études
stratégiques et internationales un de
ses critères et la direction du
lancement terre espace espace espace
espace terre ainsi les armes terre
espace comprennent les missiles
antisatellites mais aussi des lasers des
brûlures et d'autres cyber apparaît les
systèmes espace espaces sont véhiculées
par des satellites qui intercepte
désactive ou détruisent d'autres
satellites
enfin la dernière catégorie est celle
des armes espace terre il peut s'agir
d'un système de défense antimissile
opérant depuis l'espace ou même des
armes placé sur orbite qui entrent dans
l'atmosphère après la réception d'un
signal sur ces trois catégories
seulement deux types d'armement ont
obtenu des résultats terre espaces et
espace espaces le troisième espace terre
n'est toujours pas au point et aucune
information sur d'éventuels tests n'a
été publié à ce jour cette élite tueur
lasers aveuglants brouilleurs
sophistiqué la militarisation de
l'espace se poursuit à pas de géant qui
en est responsable
les états unis pointe du doigt la russie
et la chine selon washington ces deux
pays mais régulièrement des essais de
leurs armes spatiales moscou et pékin
n'ont jamais confirmé ses propos pour
eux ce sont les états unis qui provoque
la nouvelle course aux armements dans
l'espace
en effet le pentagone affiche
ouvertement son objectif de suprématie
américaine dans l'espace
toutes les tentatives de s'entendre sur
la limitation des capacités spéciales
rencontre un échec
les etats-unis et leurs alliés rejette
le projet russo chinois de prévention de
la nouvelle course aux armements
spatiale celle ci risque de s'étendre
aussi à des objets spatiaux comme la
lune par exemple washington conclut un
certain nombre de traités bilatéraux
avec ses alliés sur le partage éventuel
des ressources lunaires
la russie et la chine ils sont
farouchement opposés mais pourront elles
empêcher la réalisation de ces projets
alors
comment les principales puissances
spatiales défendre tel leurs intérêts
dans l'espace extra atmosphérique
pourquoi n'y at il toujours pas d'accord
sur la limitation des armements spatiaux
enfin quels sont les autres acteurs
géopolitiques qui développent leurs
capacités militaires spatiales pour
répondre à ces questions nous rejoignons
au sylvie matelly spécialiste de
l'économie de la défense directrice
adjointe de leiris madame mater les
beaux jours
bonjour certains pays les uns après les
autres créer leurs propres forces
spatiales pourquoi cette nécessité
apparaît telle maintenant quand on quand
on veut atteindre 2 sort spatiale en
général on est un petit peu influencé
par star wars et les films sur l'espace
et on imagine que c'est pour par la
guerre dans l'espace en réalité les
forces spatiales et qui ont été créés
elles viennent d'abord répondre à un
besoin de 2,2 dame de se donner les
moyens de se doter des moyens pour
répondre aux menaces en fait si berlin
dans le cyberespace et pour cela bien
évidemment il faut avoir des moyens qui
permettent de communiquer plus
rapidement voir des moyens d'observation
du puissant et c'est ce qui motive
l'essentiel en aide de la création de la
nouvelle création des forces spatiales
même si encore une fois la partie guerre
dont l'espace est c'est perrin n'est pas
exclue avec la terre vous puisse
imaginer que ces forces spatiales juste
aller dans cette direction
on est d'abord dans une optique de
répondre aux cyber menaces alors
pourquoi les états unis la chine et la
russie s'accusent de vouloir militarisé
l'espoir mutuellement pourquoi ils
utilisent ces mots et c'est rhétorique
du coup alors c'est très très anciens
ses craintes des états unis de la russie
et de la chine et assez paradoxalement
ce sont des pays qui ont investi le plus
tôt l'espace qui s'accusent mutuellement
de vouloir militarisé l'espace puisque
bien évidemment le risque existe on a
aujourd'hui des satellites d'observation
il ya certes des satellites
d'observation qui ont des visées civiles
qui servent à observer pour la météo
pour la circulation des bateaux et les
systèmes de géolocalisation etc
mais on a aussi des systèmes
d'observation qui sont militaires et qui
sont militarisée et donc bien évidemment
le risque c'est l'escaladé c'est une
course aux armements dans l'espace
ce que craint ce que craignent tous les
pays parce que bien évidemment qui dit
militarisation de l'espace se dit aussi
nouvelles menaces nouveaux risques et
course aux as on n'est jamais sûr d'être
le premier en tête de la crosse alors
quand vous dites une nouvelle escalade
quelles seraient ces conditions quand on
parle de la militarisation de l'espace
que peut-on dire dans les faits tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé de la
cyberdéfense alors ça peut être aussi
des lancements de satellites espions au
développement d'armes sophistiquées ou
quelque chose d'autre encore il ya
plusieurs aspects il ya l'aspect
observations effectivement qui est
plutôt dans la prévention
c'est à dire les satellites espions on
observe pour identifier très en amont
une menace mais on n'est pas encore dans
la projection de force de réaction qui
vont attaquer depuis l'espace malgré
tout on sait pertinemment que c'est le
risque quand on parle d' escalade de
course aux armements
on sait que au départ l'intention c'est
de se protéger d'une montée en puissance
et d'une supériorité éventuelle de
l'adversaire et puis à force de vouloir
se protéger bien on finit aussi d'être
sur l'installation de deux dans une
démarche plus offensive en fait elle à
l'installation de deux moyennes qui
pourrait nous permettre une attaque donc
très clairement le risque existe même si
aujourd'hui chacun des pays a bien
conscience qu'il faut à tout prix merci
beaucoup mal et à ma télé nous allons
poursuivre notre analyse tout de suite
mais nous vous retrouverons à la fin de
cette émission pour plus de détails sur
ce thème merci encore l'espace fait
aujourd'hui l'objet de tensions
diplomatiques de plus en plus forte
le 8 mars le commandant de la force
spéciale américaine y tient des propos
virulents à l'égard de la russie et de
la chine qui l'accusent de procéder à la
militarisation de l'espace
la chine et la russie disposent de
plusieurs systèmes laser basés au sol de
différents niveaux de puissance
les deux pays ont des capacités en
orbite qui sont préoccupantes et toutes
ces menaces sont là aujourd'hui
quant à la russie les américains lui
reprochent principalement un
comportement dangereux dans l'espace en
novembre 2019 la russie lance un
satellite baptisée cosmos 25,42 il
héberge sur orbite un sou satellite
cosmos 25,43 capables de manoeuvrer pour
observer et inspecté d'autres satellites
les deux objets spatiaux russes se
rapproche dans satellites espions
américains un jeu au chat et à la souris
commence en orbite provoquant une vague
de critiques des autorités américaines à
l'égard de moscou
de son côté la russie affirme que son
activité dans l'espace est conforme au
droit international
plus encore il n'y aurait aucune arme
spatiale dans l'arsenal russe selon les
autorités officielles les etats-unis eux
et essayer de prouver le contraire
à en croire le pentagone moscou
disposerait actuellement de deux types
d'armements spatiaux le premier est un
missile anti satellite lancé depuis le
seul mot secours ou leur ai testé deux
fois au cours de l'année dernière
le deuxième est un système anti
satellite opérant depuis l'espace selon
washington la russie en aurait fait un
essai en juillet 2020 le satellite
cosmos 25,43 alibert un objet à une
vitesse élevée qui est encore en orbite
et ne semble rien avoir heurté le
développement d'armes spatiale et leur
et ses supposés les autorités
américaines font quasiment les mêmes
reproches à pékin en septembre 2020 le
département de la défense américain a
publié un rapport dans lequel il est
indiqué que la chine dispose de
suffisamment de moyens pour empêcher le
déploiement des objets spatiaux d'un
adversaire potentiel brouillard de
communication laser missiles
antisatellites ou même satellite doté
d'une technologie robotique ça ne serait
qu'une partie de l'arsenal spatial
chinois
son côté la chine n'a jamais confirmé le
développement de nouvelles armes
spatiales depuis qu'elle a testé en 2007
1 missiles antisatellites seul essai de
ce genre reconnu par pékin washington en
compte plus comme par exemple en 2014
pékin parle alors de test d'un système
de défense les etats-unis eux ont la
certitude que c'est un essai deux
missiles antisatellites pourtant tout en
accusant la russie et la chine
washington ne cache pas ses ambitions
spatiales
l'ex-président américain donald trump
créé la space force et proclame l'espace
d'un nouveau domaine de combat est
aujourd'hui washington ne se limite pas
au développement des systèmes anti
satellite terrestre missiles laser
brouilleurs en juin 2020 agence
américaine de développement spatial
dévoile un système de défense opérant
depuis l'espace toujours en cours de
construction
il se compose d'une constellation de
satellites qui serait lié à un système
d'armes terrestre ces satellites aiderez
à identifier des cibles mobiles se
trouvant au delà de la ligne de visée
outre l'identification ce système aurait
différents autres objectifs traçage
protection dissuasion navigation ou
gestion et appui aux combats dans la
mise en place de ce système washington
compte aussi sur le soutien
d'entreprises privées
selon le média américain spécialisé
space news la société dit le masque
space x et l3 harris remporte en octobre
un appel d'offres pour hui en jean
spatiaux selon ses termes
les deux entreprises devront construire
d'ici 2022 quatre satellites chacun
ayant pour tâche de détecter des
missiles balistiques et hypersonique
ainsi que de suivre des lancements
éventuel depuis la terre aujourd'hui
pourtant la militarisation de l'espace
risque de prendre une nouvelle ampleur
car de plus en plus de pays songent
développement de leurs propres capacités
offensives et défensives dans l'espace
en mars 2021 la france mène le premier
exercice militaire spatial en europe qui
réunit tous les services civils et
militaires participant d'une manière ou
d'une autre à la protection des
satellites français
cet exercice
virtuel fait suite à la publication en
2019 d'une nouvelle stratégie spatiale
française qui prévoit la création de
puissants lasers déployés depuis les
satellites et depuis les nano satellites
patrouilleur français
simultanément israël mène une série de
test de son missile anti balistiques
hero iii qui aurait la capacité de
détruire des satellites en orbite basse
selon des experts toujours en 2019 new
delhi procède à un test de missiles
antisatellites devenant ainsi un des
rares pays à brandir une telle arme
enfin l'année dernière le japon créer
une force spatiale pour surveiller et
contrer les menaces pesant sur les
satellites du pays alors pourquoi les
principales puissances spatiales
n'arrive-t-elle pas à s'accorder sur la
limitation de la course aux armements
dans l'espace pourquoi la colonisation
de la lune pour était de devenir le
premier pas vers la militarisation
quelles sont les premières armes
déployées dans l'espace la réponse après
la pause
[Musique]
l'espace intersidéral se militarise à
une vitesse de plus en plus alarmante
pourtant l'utilisation de l'espace à des
fins militaires de défense et de
renseignement n'est pas nouvelle elle
prend sa source en pleine guerre froide
la conquête de l'espace commence à la
fin des années 1950 en pleine guerre
froide à la fois dans un but militaire
et pour des raisons de prestige le 4
octobre 1957 l'urss lance le premier
satellite en orbite autour de la terre
spoutnik 1 ce succès conduit le
président américain eisenhower a créé en
juillet 1958 la nasa pour rattraper les
soviétiques
dès la fin des années 1950 les deux
puissances commencent à lancer
secrètement des satellites d'observation
militaire
c'est le cas notamment du programme
américain corona et du programme
soviétique zénith
c'est à cette même période que
s'effectuent les premiers tests des
armes anti satellite en 1959 washington
lance un missile baptisé discoverer 5
depuis un avion un autre système anti
satellite développé par les américains
cette époque se base sur des missiles
nique et zeus et x destinée à
détruire les cibles situées à une
altitude de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de leur côté les soviétiques
eux mettent en place un programme appelé
chasseurs de satellites il s'agit bien
d'un missile qui explose après s'être
rapproché du satellite et demi une
certaine détente qui se produit dans les
relations américano soviétique débouche
sur la signature en 1967 d'un traité de
l'espace qui interdit entre autres de
placer en orbite des armes de
destruction massive notamment nucléaires
or la course aux armements continue
notamment dans l'espace
parallèlement au développement de
missiles antisatellites seul espace les
deux poids lourds tests à un rythme
poussée des armes à énergie dirigée dont
des lasers à la fin des années 70
washington développe son système de
navigation par satellite gps
celui ci n'avait initialement que des
objectifs militaires permettant de
spécifier des coordonnées et la position
d'une cible de diriger un mouvement des
troupes et des missiles balistiques en
même temps washington travaille sur la
création d'une nouvelle génération
d'armes antisatellites dans le cadre du
programme assat sur cinq lancement du
missile
la cible est atteinte une seule fois
l'urss
elle déclare opérationnel en 1973 son
système appelé destructeur de satellites
ayant la capacité de détruire et
d'intercepter des satellites de
reconnaissance et demi circulant sur
l'orbité basse moscou procède par la
suite à des essais de deux avions mig 31
modifiée conçue pour lancer des missiles
antisatellites or tous ces programmes
sont arrêtées avec l'effondrement de
l'urss qui bouleverse l'échiquier
mondial
pourtant washington continue dans la
même direction est publié dans les
années 90 sa doctrine du contrôle de
l'espace axé sur trois objectifs le
renforcement des moyens de surveillance
de l'espace la protection des satellites
en orbite et la mise au point d'armes
spatiale dès la fin de la guerre froide
un certain nombre de pays développent
leurs propres capacités défensives et
offensives dans l'espace exemple la
france l'allemagne l'italie le japon
israël et la chine lance leurs
satellites de reconnaissance
certains mettent en place leur système
de gps à des fins civiles
aussi bien que militaires notamment la
russie avec glonass la chine avec
compass et l'europe avec galileo
la chine elle manifeste un intérêt tout
particulier pour le développement d
armes spatiales dans les années 2000
selon washington la chine aurait
temporairement aveuglé en 2006 un
satellite d'espionnage américain qui
passait au dessus de son territoire à
l'aide d'un puissant laser
un an plus tard pékin teste son missile
lancé contre son ancien satellite
météorologique
l'essai est reconnu par pékin et est
fortement critiquée par washington qui
accuse la chine de militariser l'espace
or les états unis tests eux mêmes en
2008 un missile anti satellite lancé
depuis un croiseur une première depuis
plus de vingt ans le développement des
armes spatiales connaît un nouvel élan
avec l'arrivée au pouvoir aux états unis
de donald trump qui crée en 2019 une
force spatiale
celle ci aurait pour objectif d'assurer
la suprématie américaine dans l'espace
parallèlement l'administration trump
durci le ton à l'égard de la russie et
de la chine qu'elle accuse d'être les
principaux responsables de la
militarisation de l'espace les
accusations mutuelles se multiplient dès
lors la militarisation de l'espace
semble inévitable
l'instauration d'un régime légal
international pour l'éviter est un échec
pourquoi selon la russie et la chine la
raison de cette impasse est la position
des états unis les états unis agissons
dans leur intérêt personnel entrave
depuis longtemps de manière négative le
processus international de négociation
sur le contrôle des armements dans
l'espace
moscou et pékin ont leur propre vision
d'un éventuel traité de désarmement
spatiale depuis 2008 les deux pays
proposent dans le cadre de la conférence
du désarmement à genève un document
intitulé traité sur la prévention du
placement d'armement dans l'espace est
de l'emploi de la force contre les
objets dans l'espace
objectif l'interdiction totale et
mondial de placer des armes en orbite
or il est rejeté par les états unis et
leurs alliés
les usa défendent notamment leur liberté
d'action dans l'espace en plus et pointe
du doigt l'hypocrisie
résumé de la chine et de la russie
qu'ils accusent de continuer à mener des
tests de leur arme anti satellite en
orbite
moscou et pékin présente une nouvelle
version du document en 2014
elle est rejeté de nouveau le dernier
round de négociations date de juillet
2020 les délégations russes et
américaines se réunissent à vienne pour
discuter du contrôle des armements et de
sécurité spatiale mais de nouveaux pas
d'avancer la pierre d'achoppement reste
la notion même d'armes spatiale le défi
est qu'il est pratiquement impossible de
bien définir la notion d' armes
spatiales et même si vous y arrivez il
sera pratiquement impossible de vérifier
le respect d'un tel accord s'il est
accepté par un de ses membres
les états unis souhaitent en fait laissé
l'espace en tant que terrain de jeux
militaires tout en y introduisant
quelques règles les usa prépare donc
leur propre code de conduite dont
l'espace qu'ils espèrent présenter
bientôt à l'onu c'est ce que révèle un
haut gradé américain dans une interview
à space news sans interdire complètement
les armes spatiales
cette initiative se focalise sur trois
pointes limiter l'activité
potentiellement menaçante pour les
objets spatiaux réduire les risques de
malentendus et lutter contre les débris
spatiaux pour important ce code devrait
s'appliquer non seulement dans l'espace
mais devra aussi protéger les objets
spatiaux des menaces émanant de la terre
en 2008 l'union européenne a également
tenter d'élaborer son propre code de
conduite spatiale mais les négociations
n'ont jamais débouché sur un texte
définitif du coup en l'absence de règles
internationales les états s'engagent
unilatéralement comme par exemple la
russie en 2004 à ne pas placer
d'armement dans l'espace depuis elle
courtise des pays dans le monde entier
pour conclure avec eux des traités
bilatéraux de non prolifération
à ce jour 25 pillon signés dont
l'argentine le pakistan ou encore
l'indonésie
or parmi ces pays la majorité ne sont
pas des puissances spatiales
mais cela n'inquiète pas pour autant la
russie car pour elle ce n'est pas une
question d'applicabilité mais de poids
politique
l'accord constitue un pas dans le cadre
de la mondialisation de l'initiative
internationale relative aux noms
placement d'armement dans l'espace
confirmant la volonté des états d'unir
leurs efforts pour prévenir la course
aux armements dans l'espace
de leur côté les états unis ne reste pas
non plus les bras croisés avec leurs
alliés
il commence aussi à légiférer
unilatéralement sur leurs activités dans
l'espace exemple les accords d'artemis
d'octobre 2020 entre washington et
l'australie le royaume uni l'italie le
canada le luxembourg les émirats arabes
unis et le japon
le texte est lié au programme homonyme
américain d'exploration de la lune sans
en revendiquer la souveraineté les pays
signataires de cet accord se réserve le
droit d'exploiter les ressources
lunaires
ce texte permet aussi de créer des bases
d'exploration sur la lune et des zones
de sécurité autour de ses bases pour
prévenir les conflits avec d'autres pays
finalement il stipule que cette mission
sera conduite à des fins pacifiques mais
ne prescrit pas expressément la
participation des militaires en effet
cette participation est aussitôt annoncé
en février dernier le wall street
journal annonce la coopération entre le
pentagone et la nasa autour d'une
mission lunaire
ainsi l'armée américaine s'occupera de
la défense des opérations commerciales
américaines sur le satellite de la terre
auparavant le général des forces
spatiales américaines john cho a révélé
que le pentagone envisager de construire
une base militaire sur la lune
opérée par les robots pour y voir plus
clair nous revenons vers sylvie matelly
spécialiste de l'économie de la défense
directrice adjointe de leiris madame
matelly pourquoi selon vous les
puissances spatiales ne peuvent pas
s'accorder sur un traité interdisant la
militarisation de l'espace qui veut une
nouvelle course aux armements
il y à il ya deux aspects en fait dont
la conquête de l'espace
il y un premier aspect c'est comme vous
le dit très justement la sécurité la
défense et donc la milite à la
possibilité de militariser l'espace ce
qui aujourd'hui est
et très compliqué en fait puisque il y à
un traité qui avait été signé en dans
les années 60 à la fin des années 60 qui
interdit en réalité cette militarisation
de l'espace
et puis le deuxième aspect c'est
l'aspect commercial c'est-à-dire on sait
aujourd'hui que l'espace va être marché
potentiel va être une opportunité qu'on
potentiel pour des activités économiques
pour du profit dans les années qui
viennent donc cette complète de l'espace
est là ces deux aspects là et c'est vrai
que nous ne sommes qu un lob des
possibilités que peuvent offrir que peut
offrir l'espace et personne aujourd'hui
ne cherche ne souhaite mettre des
garde-fous
d'abord parce que la menace elle est
assez peu présent enfin il ya ces deux
présents on imagine très très bien mais
pour l'instant elle n'est pas totalement
concrètes et elle ne pousse pas à
s'entendre pour l'âme unités et puis
ensuite parce que les opportunités sont
encore peu défini on sait qu'elles sont
énormes mais elles sont encore défini et
personne ne veut se brider et y laisser
les autres en profiter parlons de la
lune et des accords artemis est ce que
ces accords sont une tentative de
contourner justement le traité de
l'espace de 1967 alors c'est une
accusation qui a été portée aux états
unis ce sont les états unis qui ont
annoncé et qui ont poussé via la nasa
la signature de ces accords artemis par
7,7 des pays proches des états unis et
on accuse les états unis parcelier de
vouloir contourner le traité de l'espace
de l'été de l'espace qui prévoit une
annonce privatisation de l'exploitation
des ressources tuner c'est une
accusation bien évidemment que démentent
les américains donc l'avenir nous le
dira on verra bien ce qu'il se quillan
est en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est
que bâle et les états unis en se prêter
de l'espace dans le viseur depuis
plusieurs années puisque déjà en 2015
une loi américaine que l'on appelait
space act avait finalement conduit à
pour les états unis à une rupture dans
ce traité de l'espace en autorisant les
entreprises américaines
arrêt des ressources disponibles dans
l'espace donc on voit que la perception
de l'espace la gestion de l'espace davot
l'enduit de capter l'espace est en
pleine évolution et que chaque pays
essaye de placer ses pions le plus vite
possible avant que les opportunités
disparu
quels sont vos prospective sur la
militarisation de l'espace extra
terrestre est la lune devient
deviendront-ils un jour un nouveau champ
de bataille
c'est difficile à dire aujourd'hui mais
je crois que le risque d'escaladé existe
aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans une
logique quand on part à la conquête de
l'espace
on est dans une logique que d'exploiter
l'espace pour observer pour espionner
vous l'avez dit mais aussi pour observer
un sens sans forcément de fausses
intentions
on est dans la logique de conquête de
l'espace puisque en allant conquérir
l'espace il ya aussi on tente aussi des
innovations et des progrès
technologiques mais on n'est pas
forcément encore dans une logique de
guerre de l'espace
malgré tout on sait que les escalades
sont rapides et que tu viens
l'observation peut conduire aller plus
loin et finalement à méditer risée de
cet espace jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait un
conflit et ont construit dans l'espace
mais s'est dit c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui d'imaginer imaginer tout ça
parce que ça relève réellement de la
science fiction
il faut souhaiter que personne n'y aura
intérêt et comme traité sera signé avant
que ça ne se produise pour réguler un
petit peu toutes ses activités à un
accord supposons aller russie etats unis
chine c'est possible pour l'instant ça
paraît peu envisageable et personne n'a
vraiment vraisemblablement envie de
signer l'accord mais dans un contexte où
on a vu la même chose avec la dissuasion
nucléaire dans un contexte où il y
aurait à ce calade mais surtout escale à
des menaces et des risques et bien la
pression sont un petit peu plus forte
sur les grands acteurs de l'espace pour
aller signer ce type d'accord c'est
clair merci beaucoup madame ma télé je
rappelle sylvie matelly spécialiste de
l'économie de la défense directrice
adjointe de l'eris était là aujourd'hui
avec nous pour apporter son éclairage
merci encore 7
partie là n'est pas encore terminée la
semaine prochaine une nouvelle partie
vous attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]